thought of it just puts me in the mood
fuck it's amazing well despite your lack
of garbage at a kick I think we can
still have a nice night together McCune
you have longer arms and your best
friend set an alarm to remind you at
2:00 a.m. to see if this ludicrous what
mythical screw of the mages is this
mystical this is the either fire but the
quick stone silver shit I have a quick
super love and spoons Kate very Kate
thank you no no no I won't have that did
you say crazy creatures yeah oh yeah
dude giggle did I write one sexist line
dragons no Charles no Triceratops no
dragon Triceratops yes really
no what the hell's our dragon
Triceratops well what a dragon no
Triceratops love each other very very
much well actually they would both lay
eggs I mean I could see that matching up
I mean dragons to send it eventually
became how can this driceratops having
babies I don't know they think we're
really tasty we wiped him out like the
Dodos don't else no no no those things
were delicious are you kidding me you
ate two toes out it was like they were
running away anywhere there were bloody
idiots you're not gonna ask about like
nymphs or tree nuts or tree spirits or
Pixies or nixies or the selkie or then
do I know more about Irish folklore than
you do news yes really yes
what is a nymph oh Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ was a nymph who is this
Jesus Christ he's a superstar does he
ride the Flying Spaghetti Monster no he
normally would ride like the de Loup
Cthulhu hey he's fantastic we voted him
in for president both 2000 and 2004
Janis Damon okay
fuck your princess being in another
castle just leave it at I you did
literally nothing but sit there the
whole time yeah all right I had my other
life I apologize
Oh greetings this young lean was almost
wasted away wasted she is wasted best
not want talking about saying way lately
try the line again
this young Ling was almost waylaid away
by bandits no no they still got the line
right and then treated her to sweet
treats inhale that makes no sense I'll
try the line again and wave yeah you
have to get out don't you get out it out
before DCFS shows up come on
improv no no come on you were never here
this is all a drink this did not pop it
this guy what you are so few circles
help yes go for it
well come on you have Myers in there
come on Circle Circle and stop whoa stop
burn you aren't ready how she
experienced
supervise in a draft government building
what is this what is this a not very
impressive fall out of props yeah how is
she experienced the welcome are you
kidding me sober it in a dread
government what is this better than
elastic blendin no and who is this
beauty of beguiling beauty my bad
no sometimes a woman just needs a man to
sweep her off her feet
he smells like trumpets Jessica be
serious did you try breaking open the
game console and to what summon more
monsters summoned Zul don't I don't
think our renters insurance is gonna
cover energy to call that horrible stuff
dozer Carl type up a resume okay I have
to type you up a resume you don't even
have a Social Security number do you you
don't even have a green card is it gonna
be hard I'll talk to HR do I just stand
here you to the pond of the Valkyries
makes it so clear so precise I'm it's
not a job it's a quest if you just
believe in yourself beautifully composed
do you all lined up
what were you doing Carl what's
happening here
okay so these is essentially the dried
caked tectonic layers I want to say of
your brother's dead skin cells from his
hand there is he's never thought to
clean this out very clearly I'm
expecting there
there's chocolate clearly some sort of
there's a lot of grains so I'm not too
happy with your brother's diet looking
at this I should also think you should
have his fingernails checked for you
know herpes how can that come from one
person's hands very clearly he lives
with this attached to his hand like this
the dust is not even coming off or out
this is like a heroin addict would not
snort this there's is so much disgust
and felt like what is this even what
could this possibly what is this gunge
that could possibly be there he I really
think your brother is trying to perform
cunnilingus on the garbage disposal I am
sharing a cubicle with son who shouldn't
even be in this world he'll help would
you please
mom mom the whole reason I bought you
call of duty will said we could spend
time together and bond Alicia hello
hello you will not believe the day that
I'm having yeah yeah you're home
suffering in an iron lung about to be
decapitated let me tell you who I had to
share a cubicle with yeah yeah I bet
that was horrible to guess what has to
happen to me and my job I have a
freeloader living on my couch from a
mythical world who's invading my job
invading my cubicle probably invading my
girlfriend I'll check later on it though
I don't care what happened on Homestuck
why are you still reading really that's
awesome yeah I should get back into that
yeah you would not believe the asshole
like to share a cubicle with freeloading
on my couch invading my job yes no I
don't care that you're 12 listen listen
no quantity soon consume fun to huntin
couch job yes yes I'll hold
hello yes mr. Chen yes I'm sorry
Wow Wow
could you say that again in English sir
yeah that's shitty too guess what I have
to do I have to share the cubicle with
the asshole
who's invading my couch he's shooting
wild animals he bangs it in a toilet yes
a toilet there is is there like a forum
you can join first sir
was it gonna be in town no I I would go
to that I would totally go to that I
didn't even know there was a fetish for
it you're awesome mom hey Noam fucker
hey Ren Faire weird al' hey chicken
broth hey Warhammer reject that's a
public fallout you know what I like you
you should do this more often I would
like to but my boss would not say boss
Jim Roth from the tailor hi you can
fucking fraggin sorry that's left it's
like Michael Attila prosciutto the the
prime of Parma the fruit of the pig the
crown jewel of Italian crowned meats I
don't even know why are your shirts off
anyway because you like it
welcome step back and shout again and do
you step forward a bit cuz you're in the
dark psi-cops on the job I know
do you want to sign up for like an
addition to be in addition to my plan
would be like five dollars extra we both
kind of say get out of here stop at you
nerd what what from where
haha I can't the murder report are doin
LeBron is riding my ass besides tonight
is the night of dear Jessica's birthday
party cocktail party ah
you guys must be pretty high if you're
interested in me
all right I got the results reports are
coming in from all over the world of
bizarre and instantaneous disappearances
of house why is it they wait till we're
in a rejuvenation chambers to run back
and forth to the ship that is what I am
trying to rejuvenate surrendered
surrendered you're in the face of this
tragic occurrence before a community has
why do I action is chested fret
what you refused to watch that Kissinger
okay that was literally he literally
that's something I got a problem with
but you know what I mean I people want
to fuck okay that was literally him
betraying his roots hang on so you could
tell the screen you're up here I'm gonna
need you down here Jesus Christ and this
little hmm it gets better
action
that's the Rickon he's good
that's the Rickon he's you can't just
strive to be the Messiah
fuckin fuck and that is that the Messiah
is the most talented man who has ever
lived that is why he is not gonna drink
either one but clean give me the pumpkin
one what's extra girls maybe somebody on
the message board is looked at it fuckin
balls someone on the message board must
have liked it clear yeah okay all right
look don't get too full of yourself all
right all right look
if if we're gay then why do we have
girlfriends why do I I don't I'm single
sit the fuck in me I have a girlfriend -
yes obvious why you're singing your
pouty pokey son of a bitch
but me I'm amazing besides what's the
fun of making fun of things and people
also can't make fun of us for it
fucking take this table over alright
because he needs us all right he needs
Jenny said she knew someone that could
help us out
there's nothing more than I'd want to do
than just fucking remember this line in
d by the way you have a stove in your
living room dining room just kidding by
the way you have a stove in your living
room dining room oh it's space lancers
Steve Jeff tells me who comes across
easy Jeff tells me we've come across
some spikes in the road we all live
together we all three of us
what I realize even looking at me but
I'm sitting way back here oh no looks
like you're looking somewhere else
aha I meant to fuck it up you can't get
unemployment now and quitting means you
can't go back to the temp agency we all
live in this place together and I cannot
carry all three of our asses for another
month
hey I have a job yes yes you do honey so
we break into your house it's what I
want to do yeah I love movies I love
being funny
I love talking about would it be a car
salesman action and do that while still
working another job
look at Jeff lubbers papers videos mr.
McFeely was the bag okay then do that
while you're still working another job
look at Jeff delivers papers in the
morning in the afternoon
morning in the afternoon who works on
those videos in the evening until your
videos start supporting our life and
okay with her ex-boyfriend went to jail
I made sure he stick dude space later
Steve's rescue ship gets marooned in
space it's a perfect opportunity to
blast away it's a perfect opportunity to
test leave motherfuckers popping and
locking Brian I was doing double dream
and so the nail dungeon everything
hey wait what else would you have space
Lancer Steve talking about why he's
revealing it yes he's holding you back
darling mooching off your check that
every hour yeah if I want to hear
someone yell like that I'll track down
the owner and fuck his mom in the ass I
mean fucking lost it I think it's this
dumb pricks wife getting fucked in the
ass by the neighbor and fucking hell and
what about this spaceman that's
obviously filming in his parents
driveway I mean shit fucking ass
pounders I mean ass pounding coma he's
the fucking pair of them
it's just they link to each other's
video Jesus probably like they take
turns making each other's asshole bleed
oh my god why can't I talk today hey I
am count Thomas Howard your host for
this evening festivities for some
fucking cars to drive by call your busy
street I know there are car there this
well it's a good thing you've already
emptied your bowels cuz you're about to
get a fucking fuck okay
you don't have to move your gun or
anything okay
and that while we're waiting for my
rescue ship to show up let's talk about
Jason ghost